quand tu craches et devient un geste de
santé publique c'est rare mais pour les
tests salivaires anti cowitz est
obligatoire le lycée descartes de tours
a inauguré aujourd'hui ce nouveau type
de dépistage pour ces élèves d'autres
écoles vont en bénéficier dans les
prochains mois pour casser les chaînes
de transmission
alors comment ça marche le reportage de
romain des villes salles d'attentes à
ciel ouvert pour les 34 volontaire du
lycée descartes de tours je pense que
c'est utile parce que au moins on sait
qui était à symptomatique est comme ça
on tâte éviter un petit peu plus la
propagation de ce virus et au moins si
on est testé massivement dans les écoles
ça peut nous éviter aussi la fermeture
et ça peut nous éviter de le donner à
nos familles quand elles viennent nous
voir le week-end quand on rentre dans
nos familles respectives
j'ai mon selon charlotte alors brioux
brio de marianne
à l'intérieur du foyer les tests
salivaires attendent les élèves
ça l'est vraiment on n'est pas sauvage
dans le crachin vraiment c'est juste
saluer la fermeture en plus ce petit
tube jusqu'au niveau n'a pas mal ça
tourne pas voilà j'ai ici quand ses
prêtres lève la main et puis on vient de
recevoir l'accord les propos de sa
libyen lèvres pincées accumulation de
bave chacun chacune a sa technique
et apparemment ce n'est pas si évident
de ne livrer que la salive sans mousse
et sengler l'objectif c'est de détecter
les personnes qui sont contaminées par
l'aco vide mais qui sont asymptomatiques
les brigades de prélever de préleveurs
sont envoyés dans des établissements de
secteurs où des cas positifs ont été
déclarés le virus circule ce qui fait
que tous les jours on sera amené à
déclencher une brigade dans un
établissement scolaire la semaine
prochaine trois écoles du département
accueilleront des campagnes de tests
salivaires bien moins invasifs pour les
enfants que les prélèvement
rhinopharyngé